this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all
that all good things good mood good
performance good everything
seem to stem from good sleep so i've
tried a lot
to optimize and i've tried pills and
potions
all sorts of different mattresses you
name it and for the last few years i've
been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
in like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free
they'll even pick it up from you if you
don't love it and now my dear listeners
helix is offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim
these are not cheap pillows either so
getting two for free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep dot com slash tim for up to 200
off so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep dot com slash
tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs the global creative platform
that makes it easy for you to find and
work with amazing graphic designers
online long long-time listeners of this
podcast know how much attention
i paid to detail how obsessively i
approach nearly all elements
of my work because the small things
often end up being the big things so
whether it's your logo
your business cards website design even
your email templates all of these visual
elements tell your customers tell your
users
who you are and what you're about so i
think it's worth sweating the details
i've been using 99designs for years now
to ensure that many of my creative
projects whether big or small
are as cohesive professional and
beautiful as possible
i've worked on draft mock-ups of book
covers
i've worked on all sorts of things most
recently i've been working with a
designer at 99designs to update the
illustrations and layouts for all of my
downloadable ebooks i've developed a
really great working relationship with
the designer who goes by
the username spoon lancer and i intend
to continue working with him to bring
ideas to life one project at a time
i've also used 99 designs for all sorts
of
high-end illustration for different
books like the tao of seneca you can see
a bunch of examples on my instagram that
i've put up
and they've turned out better than i
possibly could have hoped
so from logos to websites to packaging
to books
99designs is the go-to creative resource
to build your brand on any budget
so check them out right now my listeners
that's you guys can get 20
off plus a free 99 upgrade on
their first design contest contest is a
great way to get started and find the
right designer
for long-term work you can also book a
free design consultation with a brand
expert at 99designs to receive
personalized branding advice over the
phone
their hands-on team has helped thousands
of business owners at this point
it's a great way to get the most out of
your experience with 99 designs
so take a look head to 99designs.com
tim for your discount and to sign up for
design consultation today
that's 99designs.com
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissues
[Music]
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show where it
is always my job to deconstruct
world-class performers from all
different fields and it is a rare treat
when i get to interview someone
who also works with world-class experts
across
many domains because they're able to
spot patterns and figure out frameworks
that i love to then try to emulate and
imitate and use in my own life
my guest today is dr jim lehrer
l-o-e-h-r
jim is a world-renowned performance
psychologist and author of 17 books
including his most recent leading with
character which also comes with
and i think this is important we'll
probably touch on this the personal
credo journal
a companion to leading with character
and we will no doubt get into
journaling quite quickly he also
co-authored the national bestseller
the power of full engagement and
dr lair has worked with hundreds of
world-class performers from the arenas
of sport
business medicine and law enforcement
this includes fortune 100 executives
fbi hostage rescue teams and military
special forces
his website is jim lair jim hyphen
l-o-e-h-r-dot-com you can find him on
social media
places like linkedin and elsewhere but i
thought we could start
simply by welcoming you to the show jim
welcome to the show
thank you tim i'm excited to be with you
i'm uh
hopeful that people can get some value
out of our interaction i love the time
we can spend together
it's really fun to be having this
conversation on the podcast finally you
and i have had
quite a bit of interaction prior to this
you were in tribe of mentors
you and i have spent time together
exploring
the game of tennis and i thought
that it might be helpful just for people
to visualize
your background and some of your
clientele could you name just a few
of the sports clients you have worked
with
i've learned as much from them
as they might have learned from me
because it's been an evolutionary
journey for me but i've been fortunate
to work with
over 100 of the best tennis players in
the world
including jim currier and novak djokovic
and
i've had the opportunity to work with
lots of different women on the women's
tour like monica selles
and golfers marco mara all the way up to
players i'm still working with players
on the tour
i've worked with just about every sport
eric lindros
and mike richter and hockey and ray boom
boom mancini
in boxing with this title fight of
hector macho camacho
and lots of olympic sports worked with
dan jansen for two years
prior to his olympic sensational victory
these have all been kind of my teachers
i've been very fortunate to be in the
lives of so many and most of these
people become friends for the rest of my
life because
we were involved so deeply and i feel
very privileged to have had the
opportunity to
to be involved in their lives and to
learn from them now
the long arms and you do have long arms
but the the long arms of jim layer
with his size 15 shoes am i remembering
that correctly never good memory
[Laughter]
i work with riley of pelkin he's seven
he's a tennis player
and he's uh almost seven feet i don't
know how he's seven feet but he has size
15 feet we have the same size feet and
i'm not
seven feet so i have a problem here
but the long arms of jim lehrer reach
out and touch
many people outside of these top
performers
you named including for those people who
don't know
uh some backstory with yours truly and
i'm a hobbit in stature in comparison
but
when i was in high school very briefly
i'll tell this story and i'm
certainly by no stretch a world-class
athlete but
i was a wrestler in high school i
transferred schools
and i will say from an attribute
perspective
very mediocre and my attributes were
moldable but i would not say i had any
particular special
skill and i somehow came across this is
effectively pre-internet mental
toughness training for sports
and through that book through
having those close to me my wrestling
coach my teammates
and teachers and resident advisors
produce an inventory for me of my
strengths and weaknesses and so on
i was able to have the most successful
sports season
up to that point and certainly ever
since in any sport
not to say i know a lot of sports but
the impact of that book was really
tremendous on me i ended up getting to
the prep nationals and i want to
emphasize for everyone that the prep
nationals are not the same as the
nationals
the real wrestlers go to the non-prep
nationals the prep nationals have polo
shirts and
you know kids with very different set of
skill levels but
nonetheless was able to in my little
pond get to the prep nationals and end
up
i guess top 10 in the 152 weight class
that year and i attribute a lot of that
certainly to my coach john buxton was
amazing and and many of his athletes
would credit him with a lot in their
lives but also mental toughness training
for sports so
what you do and what you teach
although it is refined with these
world-class performers also applies
to lowly hobbits like myself
in areas ranging from wrestling
to the boardroom or any other set of
domains and so i'm just
giving you a quick set of brags because
i know you're
loath to do it yourself but i want to
provide a data point for people who
might be listening and wondering how all
this would apply if they're not
someone like monica seles you mentioned
a name
that i think pairs well with my
experience because
journaling became a big part of my
experience
and in my wrestling workouts which i
recorded and my weight training workouts
that season
i wrote at the top love the pain now one
could psychoanalyze the hell out of that
because uh
you know wrestling is often a a sport of
suffering but
learning to out suffer everyone in all
things is not necessarily the path to
all things
great and pleasant nonetheless that was
at the top of my journal and it did work
at the time i'd like you
to unpack for us please a
journal heading which is 35
colon 99 and then in all caps i love the
1000.
who does this belong to and tell us
about it please
well this is uh a really great friend
after having gone through so much
together this is the story of dan jansen
i think one of the greatest stories in
sports history because it's such a
tribute
to his dedication and the power of the
human spirit
dan's agent came and said listen would
you please work with
dan jansen he will be an olympic
champion if we can get him
to fully release his talent and skill
he's had a really terrible situation
happen to him
and he's struggling and he may go down
as the
greatest choker in sports history unless
we can get him
elevated to another plateau with
the challenges that he faces and would
you mind taking dan on
so i said i i know about dan i know
about his story i'd love to meet with
them and so
the back story is that dan was
one of the greatest speed skaters out of
the blocks almost he was
he's got an extraordinarily wonderful
family he was just
seemed like a natural for speed skating
and
he in his second olympics at calgary he
was slated to win an olympic gold medal
in the 500 meter
and one of the closest people in his
life
was his sister jane and she had leukemia
and he had no idea that she was in
serious trouble
and just hours before his race he got a
call
saying that his sister jane had died and
i mean um you can't imagine what a blow
this was to him
it was somebody that was so close to him
he would have left in a heartbeat
and just left the olympics and gone to
be with her if you thought that was
going to happen but he had no knowledge
no one really knew
he really thought well what should i do
here he was going to not
skate and then his father said what do
you think jane would want you to do
and he thought about it and he said i
think she would want me to skate
so without much preparation at all this
was literally hours before the race
he puts his skates on he is in tears
and he tries to mobilize himself to
win this race it and to get through it
somehow but he's completely off center
emotionally
and just a few feet into the start dan
jansen falls
and dan jansen rarely falls he just
doesn't
and he felt a great sense of failure not
only did he fail
in the race he failed her because he
really wanted to do something special
for her
four days later was the 1000 which he
was supposed to not have any
real hope for you know really succeeding
and he thought about not doing it but
his father and his family said please do
this do this
so he specifically dedicated this race
to jane
he put his skates on mobilize himself
over four days
and he was leading the entire race
and he had a pretty good margin of
success which would have been
unbelievable and he fell again to the
ice
and came in last and thus began
the real story of dan jansen it was
about two years
before albertville which he would
compete again
and the press was merciless they kept
asking him
will you fall again have you gotten this
death of your sister
out of your mind what's gonna happen
so he went to albertville and again he
did not have a good race
and then it was after albertville two
years later was going to be
that was four years after calgary two
years later he would be
and lilly hammer you know he he didn't
fall
but he slept in albertville and he came
in
26th in the race on the thousand meter
he just
was not able to compete at all and then
we started working together and i had
him do lots of things but as you said
one of the things was
that i'm a stickler for training logs i
believe writing and
and really keeping track of all the
critical variables from
all the physical issues that are going
on diet nutrition exercise recovery
stress
and then all the emotional issues that
are going on
and all the recovery and stress cycles
in that and mentally
and even spiritually how he's doing how
he is feeling about his life
and about this sport of speed skating
and where it fits in
and i have every single log that he made
for we monitored 21 variables for
two consecutive years one of the things
i've had him put
on i asked dan what what would you like
to finish your career with what would
really be
something that would be deeply
satisfying and he said well
i'd love to just have some kind of an
olympic success
i mean i've had none and he said this is
my last olympic event i will not
skate again i'd like to have an olympic
victory of some kind
and i would like to if possible break
the 36 second barrier which was thought
at that time to be the barrier it's like
the four minute mile for roger bannister
it's something that
human beings will never be able to
break and i said okay i want you
and your training logs for the remainder
of your time i want you to write
35.99 and i want you to start believing
that that will be possible for dan
jansen before the end
of your career i said now i'm going to
ask you to do something else because i
know you
you're going to resist this one i want
you to write on the top of your
training log i love the 1000
because dan johnson did not love the
1000
he actually felt he was a fast muscle
twitch kind of a guy he was a sprinter
he hated the endurance event he always
got tired he just did it for training
purposes
and i said dan i've watched you skate
over and over
and over again and i can tell you you
have such
genius you could win an olympic gold
medal even in the thousand
and i want you to begin to change your
mindset
the story you have around your around
the thousand
and i believe it can change your life
and i also knew that the 500 is
unforgiving
if you make the slightest mistake in the
500
you're going to be out you will not get
an olympic medal and probably end up
somewhere deep in the pack
the 1000 meter is more forgiving and you
can actually have a little hiccup here
and there and still
still win the entire thing dan resisted
but he said i don't love the 1000 i know
you don't i said but we're going to
recondition
the way you think about it and the way
you feel about it and at one point
you're going to come back and tell me
that you actually love the 1000
and that's exactly what happened before
lily hammer he actually broke
the 36 second barrier three times one at
35
90 uh let's see what was it 3576 it was
and uh which is absolutely mind-boggling
to anyone who knew the sport at that
time
and he came to me and he said before
lillyhammer he said you know i'm
actually starting to like the thousand
i'm not sure i like the thousand better
than the 500.
and that just shows you how amazing
it is when you start realizing how
how much influence we have over the
categories of our thinking and how we
feel emotionally
all we have to do is tap in make the the
inputs
and make them regularly and the brain is
so plastic so flexible so pliable
it will come around and so
lily hammer came and he had uh
not a not a fall but he had a minor slip
on the 500
he did not win a medal of course he was
devastated
and i didn't tell dan because i would
normally not go to his events
i flew to lillyhammer and was in the
audience
and i had to hide because i didn't want
him to see me because i thought it might
put a little extra pressure
on him when he lost the 500 i wanted him
to know i was there
because we had four days to prepare for
the final race of his life
and i had to fight through security and
they tried to prevent me from getting
close to him
and i yelled out to dan dan it's jim and
he looks over at me and he's
you know he's very sad and he looks at
me says oh my god let him through
so i got him we went down into the
bowels of the
arena there where he was on his exercise
bike and i mean i could tell you me and
stories about all that as well but
everyone felt badly for dan because they
knew he was
the best speed skater he'd broken all
the records but he didn't get an olympic
medal
we had four days and the mindset that
created i think this extraordinary
outcome was that
dan jansen went into that race simply
showing
the whole world what a gift speed
skating
had been for him and all the wonderful
joys
and he really wanted to show the joy
that had
been given to him through this sport and
kind of a
gratitude for all the sacrifices people
had made
to give him the opportunity to do this
special thing that he loved so much
so he wasn't going out just trying to
rock a world record or anything else he
went into that
race simply trying to show
the joy on his face how much love he had
for the sport
and how grateful he was for the
opportunity
and lo and behold
dan jansen not only made it
extraordinary in terms of a performance
he won
an olympic gold medal he broke an
olympic record
in the same event that two years earlier
he had come in 26th in the world
and there were seven people in that race
including kevin scott who had faster
times than he had ever had
and kevin scott was the world record
holder at that time
i mean you can imagine the celebration
the joy
i even get a little choked up when i
talk about it because i was in tears
before the 500 i was in tears completely
throughout the whole race
because dan jansen was one of the people
that you get so connected he's such a
good
solid human being from a great family
and he deserved to win he deserved to
finish that story
the way it was finished it's a wonderful
teaching
moment for anyone who gets into that
story
had a profound effect on everyone who
knew dan
it had a profound effect on me just in
the sense that
dan had done everything that we had
asked him to do
and he did it with great engagement
he never held back i felt he deserved it
so
that story is an indelible story but
i've had so many stories that are
similar but maybe not in exactly the
same
that have touched my life and have
helped me learn
and actually increase my understanding
of this remarkable connection between
mind
and body thank you for telling that
story
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked
all the time what i would take if i
could only take one
supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance i recommended it in fact
in the four-hour body this is more than
ten years ago and i did not get paid to
do so
with approximately 75 vitamins minerals
and whole foods sourced ingredients
you'd be very hard-pressed to find a
more nutrient-dense and comprehensive
formula on the market it has
multivitamins
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it
once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i focus on nutrient-dense meals
to begin with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around right now
athletic greens is giving my audience a
special offer
on top of their all-in-one formula which
is a free vitamin d supplement
and five free travel packs with your
first subscription
purchase many of us are deficient in
vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so
adding a vitamin d supplement to your
daily routine is a great option for
additional immune support support your
immunity
gut health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
one of the conversations that i recall
we had
in florida when i was doing my
in retrospect pretty hyper aggressive
six hours a day from zero i remember
your blisters very vividly
yeah which i'll take you know full
credit for uh i'm
sort of infamous for enjoying at least
in the beginning going from
absolutely zero to something like six
hours a day and expecting it not
to have severe consequences but i
remember
a conversation that we had at one point
and i ended up paraphrasing it and
putting it in
to trump mentors and i just want to read
it and then
follow up on it here's the paragraph and
i want you to please feel free to fact
check and correct any of this
and i am paraphrasing but the power
broker in your life is the voice that no
one ever hears
in other words the voice in your head
how well you revisit the tone and
content of your private voice is what
determines the quality of your life it
is the master storyteller and the
stories we tell ourselves are our
reality
could you speak to that correct it add
to it in any way i think this is such an
important point
and i then want to follow up with a
question about
how you help the people you work with
to improve the tone and content of that
private voice
but if you could speak to that in any
way that makes sense i would love to
hear it absolutely i mean i
you just i believe kind of uncovered
what is one of the great nuggets and
something that i did not understand
um even from the world of psychological
science
sports psychology and performance
psychology it was not clearly
articulated enough so he could really
understand it but i began i spent
so many years listening to the voices
trying to get inside the heads of
players we had them wear
microphones and i could hear and they
were to articulate everything that they
said to themselves during a competitive
event
and whether it be in golf or tennis or
whatever and
as i began to realize what really
mattered
in a really significant way was the tone
and the content as you said
of the voice no one hears i came to
understand
that the ultimate coach for all of us in
life
is that private voice and that private
voice can be brutal
can actually be a detriment to being the
best you can be
it could detriment your happiness to a
sense of satisfaction in life
that voice we don't even know where for
sure it comes from but we know it begins
to form
as early as five years of age and it
comes
principally from the authority figures
in your life the people who had the most
influence in your life at that time
we take on their voices however
functional or dysfunctional
because we in a sense want to be like
them we want to grow up and be
strong or whatever it is independent
like they were
and so we get all these voices in our
head
and some of them are you know if you had
a rough father or if you had a mother
who was
you know harsh or you know doting or
didn't want you to be involved in
anything that you might get hurt
all those voices it's not like they
are not being somehow laid down in some
way particularly when the themes
are consistent and what
we learned was that the more an in
an individual can understand what that
voice is saying to them
what the tone of that voice is they can
begin to
look at this and see wait a minute is
this really helping me
or is it really am i carrying a lot of
baggage here
and these are voices these are not my
voices even though
it seems to be my voice i'm carrying the
voices of a lot of other people
and if those voices are constructive
it's fantastic
that's the greatest thing a parent can
do is to kind of help
their sons and daughters develop
magnificent voices of wisdom that are
coaching them all the time
with the right stuff so
kind of the rule of thumb that we use
let's say you're a competitor
the way you speak to yourself is the way
you would speak to someone you deeply
cared about during that competitive
event what would you say to them
and would you ever want the voice
that's coming to you to be projected
onto the jumbotron
of some great big arena because you're
proud of the messaging
that that voice is giving you it's great
advice it may be stern it may be
you know encouraging it may be
challenging it may be a lot of things
but you're proud of it
it's the best coaching advice you could
get from anyone
and that's why we want to be around
great coaches because we begin to take
on their wisdom
and that wisdom is imparted to our voice
so i'm always encouraging
athletes to develop their voice develop
that private voice
and to make sure that whatever that
voice is articulating to them
the advice the languaging and the tone
is something that that's how they would
coach someone that they cared about
because it's the best that that you have
to give
and that sometimes takes years to
develop but it's
awareness and it is a very tough thing
what are some steps if people wanted to
experiment with this do you have any
suggestions for how someone might begin
to develop this awareness because
on one hand i'm sure there are people
who can
with the intention to be more aware of
self-talk
elicit some degree of change just
through that awareness and then there
are
i would imagine many many people i think
myself included who
have such ingrained habits of thought
and
have absorbed so many thought patterns
and speech patterns from parents and
other caretakers and so on
that they might kick the [ __ ] out of
themselves
all day until the very end of the night
and they're like wow i've been a real
[ __ ] to myself all day
and they're not able to sort of
catch the thought trap it in the amber
and work with it in the moment do you
have any advice for those people
well first of all it's very normal that
everyone has a private voice everyone
has an inner voice that's speaking to
them
some more than others and sometimes that
voice is extremely harsh difficult
challenging and you would you say things
to yourself you would never say to any
other human being and you would be so
embarrassed if it was made public
and then if i were to ask you where does
that come from you'd say i well i said
you know
is there any of that in anyone in your
life and they often say you know it's a
lot like my father's the way my father
used to talk to me
that's the way my mother would talk to
me they don't really recognize
its toxicity until you bring it to their
attention
they begin to kind of lay it out very
openly and so the first step is
awareness
awareness of you know just start in the
morning and
every time something happens that isn't
exactly the way you want it to go and
maybe it's your fault
listen to what kind of coaching advice
or what kind of
talk that you're actually are you
scolding
are you very derogatory
are you positive in terms hey let's get
this going hey we all make mistakes
let's try to get better how can i get
better in this and
actually i ask people to start writing
down in their journal
periods of time that they can actually
reflect on
what that was and it's often very
shocking
and you can begin to see you're actually
fighting a couple battles you're
fighting one with yourself
if you're a competitor and then you're
fighting the golf course
you're fighting your opponent on the
other side you have two battles you have
to win
and there's somebody inside you that is
always scot-free
that has a better judgment never
responsible for any of this but just
literally lays blame on everything that
goes on in your life
to your stupidity or ignorance you dumb
head
and so that is a form of energy
expenditure i call it
that really is not only
wasted energy but it is actually having
an impact the brain listens to
everything you say
the brain hears everything you say so if
you say i have a
i hate my forehand i will never have a
great forehand in tennis
you know there's something that's being
listened to around that
and it's very possible that that will
become a huge barrier to you and take
much longer for you to overcome some of
the obstacles as opposed to i'm going to
have
one of the greatest forehands or i'm
going to be one of the greatest putters
in golf history i'm not that person yet
but believe me whatever it takes i'm
going to spend the time and energy i'm
going to get there
and so we we start scripting that and i
have people keep
you know a journal of how they want to
speak to themselves in situations that
have given them trouble they
literally script it out they write it
out
so these are the situations that have
given me trouble if you double fault for
the fifth time
three in a row how do you want to speak
to yourself
and you write that out and you write it
and you read it and you write it and you
read it
it becomes your i love the 1000 it
becomes
35.99 you begin to set
a whole new neural pathway for energy to
flow
that actually is consistent with maybe
the best coaching advice you could get
and so you begin to get smarter and
smarter about the language that actually
serves you best some really feel very
adequate when they are not speaking a
lot when they're very quiet
inside others come forth and they have
kind of this
monologue that they have and it's always
a very positive monologue
and when things go sour they know
exactly what gear to kick in
but this is what really was quite a
shock to me
was that we learned that journaling was
probably the best way
scripting how you want to speak to
yourself in advance
and reading it and going over it again
and rewriting it
was the most direct way to get it
re-ignited
in your brain in the way you want so
journaling
writing is the most direct function to
the executive function of the brain
to thought patterns and that's why if i
were to ask you what's the one thing you
would do if you wanted to remember
something you'd say
probably i'd write it down and we found
in our work and this is how i like to
learn i love huge data sets i love
you know just data trends and what we
found was that people are much better
writing it down
using cursive writing
because there's something about moving
the fingers of your hand
that is better than moving the inputs
that are
going on from striking a keyboard so
and answer to your question for me the
most
direct way is first awareness then
decide how you want to speak to yourself
then hold yourself accountable and then
start doing your writing
and try to bring that forth and it's not
just and maybe more importantly in sport
but it is in all of life
and once you get that voice right you
know your happiness your feeling of
satisfaction
you've got a great coach in your head
and that will be with you and that'll be
the only coaching voice you'll have
until your death and it's the only one
that no one else can hear if we zoom in
on
[Music]
how to use the script so let's just say
for the sake of argument it's a tennis
player
and they are
going through practice sessions and
they do something that often produces a
harsh inner critic
so they they fault in some way or they
they make the same mistake twice in a
row would they at that
point simply have the script
already memorized and rehearse saying it
to themselves in those moments would
they
walk to the sideline and grab a notebook
in which they've written this down
and read it as a reminder and then go
back out on the court
how have you seen that implemented well
it's interesting that
you know it's just like a muscle you
don't know how strong the muscle
is until you exceed its limits
until it fails and sometimes you have
what you think is a pretty strong
foundation now with your private voice
but in this situation you've been you
felt you were cheated
you felt the person is showing you
disrespect
it's a situation where you're playing
you know maybe the worst you've played
that you can remember
and you just as you see sometimes a
professional player that's it's very
unusual they just go over and smash a
rocket
and they're they kind of check out
so there's a situation that when it came
their
whatever capacity they had was exceeded
and they kind of went over the edge
and now they have to pull themselves
back first of all they typically feel if
it's
in the middle of a match they typically
feel maybe a little relief but on the
other hand they feel like they've kind
of made a fool of themselves
unless there's somebody like curios who
kind of does it
kind of all the time that's kind of his
standard operating procedure
it really calls on their resiliency to
leave that behind
and then they need to go that night and
you know write about you know what
happened and what they would prefer
next time they end up in that situation
and again i keep taking people back to
who they really want to be
how do they want to lead themselves and
what's the image they want to create for
others what for them is the ultimate
competitor
so often in tennis you'll have feder
you'll have nadal
and you'll say have you ever seen nadal
do that
have you ever seen fed act like that and
they're going to know
and i said if that's your model how do
you think they're speaking to themselves
when something really has that ever
happened to them where they've really
performed miserably and actually walked
off a court having
really left what they consider to be you
know their best performances
somewhere else it just didn't happen and
they always say yes anybody that knows
the game and the same with nadal
but they've become remarkable
inspirations to people
and if you could get inside their heads
if you start
looking how they're acting with their
physical bodies you can pretty much
guess how they're coaching themselves
and i do the same thing with ceos that
have
catastrophic news or people in business
that
have during this pandemic have had to
furlough
some of their most important valued
people and what they feel
and i always take them back to the
leaders that they
most admire how how would they handle
this how how do you
show strength and
a sense of perspective and belief
in the future for everyone and you got
to show that as opposed to
because a lot of people are watching
it's perspective
and it's hard work and you're not going
to have a muscle that holds up unless
you work the heck out of it
and these muscles of character muscles
of performance strength like resiliency
and focus they have to be strong because
they're going to be tested
and you're not always passing the test
let's talk about
leading with character you have this new
book
and my team very quickly noted that it
came with a journal
we've been talking about journaling so
we can segue really
any way that makes sense perhaps
you could describe what the intention of
the journal
is with leading with character and then
back
into why this book and why you decided
to put the energy into this book
in order to understand the journal and
why i would even suggest this and the
journal is
very challenging it's 10 minutes a day
but
it's gonna take you i just talked to
somebody who's been in their sixth day
and he said i've never
it was a very high-ranking person who's
been through a lot
he says i've never been pushed quite
like this journal is pushing me
and i start the whole thing with with
something that i began
written about on the powerful engagement
in other books but this notion of
managing your energy
and i just want to make a couple
comments about that i began to learn
that our most important resource as
human beings is not time
we were fed a bill of goods when the
time management industry said that if
you want to be successful
the most important thing you need to do
is to carve out time align it with your
deepest values
and just devote time to those highest
priorities
and for me that didn't work because i
could watch athletes in
competing playing practicing and it
wasn't the amount of time that they
spent it was the energy they brought
to the time they had aligned with what
the objective was
and i said you know the most precious
resource we have is not time but energy
we are vessels of energy and as long as
we have energy
we can have an impact and i began to
realize that every time
you invest energy in something you spawn
growth
if you give a lot of energy to sarcasm
and cynicism
and scapegoating what's going on
those will grow in your life you can
have the largest impatience muscle on
the planet all you have to do is like
going into the gym you have to invest
a lot of energy in your bicep you can
have a world-class bicep but you've got
invest energy
in that bicep and that is what i call
stress
it's the investment of energy is stress
and recovery is
the recapturing of that energy so the
journal is a way to expand
energy in the service of something and
for me the journal
is in the service of building the most
important
character strengths converting
weaknesses into strengths
and there are different types of
character one is performance character
which enables you to become an
extraordinary high achiever
and that's things like focus and
determination and ambition
and discipline and on and on and then
there's this category
of moral and ethical character and
they're very distinct
and one can have one without the other
and we get them all confused
one you have courage which is just the
courage maybe the courage to take a shot
in the last moment of a game
that's not moral courage moral courage
is the ability to step
up and do something according to what
your beliefs are even though you know
there could be a really big cost to you
if you do it
so these strengths of
moral and ethical character for in our
work
in all the data that we collected began
to show and this was a complete surprise
to me
showed the greatest impact over time
on sustained great performance and you
can be a
incredible performer and have virtually
very few moral and ethical strengths
you just get there in any way you can
you don't really care
about the impact you can cheat your way
take shortcuts
you you know you walk over dead bodies
to get to the top of the mountain
and then there are those that have this
amazing capacity to care about others
it's really your treatment of others
and for me and i didn't have this in the
early part of my career even
even a hint of it in terms of the
understanding was that your treatment of
others
is really the gold standard that we
always use and will use
to determine our success as human beings
on this planet
and that journal ends up after 150 days
about 25 hours of hard work determining
the priority you have values help you to
prioritize what you think is important
in your life
and to make sure that you're operating
and your energy is invested in ways that
reflect that
your life reflects it and when you're
going to put together a document i call
a personal credo
and that credo is the most precise
articulation
the most reflected and intensive
search for what you believe
will represent the source code for all
of your moral and ethical decisions your
energy investments going forward in life
and something magical happens we piloted
this for 10 years with some of the most
extraordinary people
and we kept refining it and working it
and
i will tell you it's not for the faint
of heart but what it does is it helps
you
we don't have a source code most of us
have no idea where our moral and ethical
machinery came from but we're making
moral and ethical decisions sometimes
eight to ten times a day
and we don't have any idea what we're
referencing we don't even know where it
came from
most say that came from parents some say
it came from their religious teachings
and some say it just seems to show up
from life we don't know exactly
your peer groups your culture so the 10
minutes a day
in the most reflective moments of peace
and quiet that you can find in your day
so that you can begin to really get into
the essence
of what is important in your life who do
you really want to be
in the time you are here where do you
want to invest your energy
how important is humility
is trustworthiness is kindness
is compassion of deeply caring and
loving
others and accepting others respecting
others
of being patient with others what i
think would be
really interesting to people listening
is
perhaps giving an example of an exercise
that you could walk people through that
would be
reflective of something that you think
has
a high return on investment or any kind
of sort of high leverage
exercise or question that if people
listening to this could be anywhere like
you said they're locked in so
certainly i mean the book fills this in
in great detail but for those people who
want
a taste of things something they could
do maybe they're out walking their dog
for the next 30 minutes and they have
the space
is there something that people could try
on absolutely
i'll give you a couple examples tim that
had a profound effect on me and
something i was not
prepared for what i got we did this with
thousands of people so
this is how this whole system evolved
so i ask people to
just think about who they are when
they're most proud of themselves
when they are at what they would
consider to be their very best
and particularly in a stressful
circumstance
who they are physically who they are
emotionally
who they are mentally who they are
spiritually
sometimes you show up and you're so
proud of how you showed up in that very
challenging moment
and you're not even sure where it came
from but it happened it's not a fantasy
sometimes this actually happens so i
asked them to write down
the words that let's say we write six
words down sometimes i say eight
like i do in the book i say eight
because that's how our original exercise
was
but have you write down the six words
that would best describe
you at your absolute best when you're
most proud
when you do that and you reflect on that
for a moment
there will be things that start to pop
up and so i would give people
five minutes six minutes to do it just
to clarify so the six to eight words
are really just a starting point and
then if things begin to flow they
continue to journal for that five minute
period well all i want at this point
in this exercise is just the six words
or the eight words
that you believe are representative
of you when you're most proud of
yourself
and often in a stressful circumstance
when you are the best you can be
and that's it that's as far as we go at
this moment
got it okay then i collect those
or i ask people to read out loud
what those words were we go around the
whole let's say there's 30 people in the
group
and when we're finished everyone is in
the state of shock
because they believe that everyone
copied
from their paper because everyone came
up
with the same bloody things almost you
know it was incredible
noticeably absent from the list
were the things that people often feel
like they're chasing
you know i feel like i'm you know i'm at
my best when i'm winning
when i'm making a lot of money when i'm
uh
winning titles when i am uh finishing a
great paper that just got
accepted by a peer-reviewed group in
some journal
on and on and on no one ever mentioned
those things
they would mention things like when i'm
100
there fully engaged with others when i'm
trustworthy when i'm
compassionate when i'm kind and
there was no prompting nothing but they
were they went almost
immediately to this moral and ethical
category for determining who they were
at their
best so then we did another exercise and
i'd ask your listeners to do the same
and it is equally shocking and it's
along the same lines and so
i asked them to write down six or eight
of the words that they would like
inscribed
on their tombstone if these words
actually reflected who they truly were
when they were here these are true what
would you like
inscribed most importantly
in the highest priority on your
tombstone
and this is you know you you have passed
now but you would like to have these
representing who you were when you were
here
and so people five six seven minutes
they write them down
and i ask people to read their list
and everyone absolutely freaks out
because the list is pretty much the same
across the whole room and no one coached
anybody about anything
and again the words that kept you know
showing up a loving father
and no one said i you know i was able to
achieve
i made ceo of a fortune 50 company or i
became
i won an olympic gold medal in my event
three times or
you know none of that was on any level
was present
what they were actually referencing
was their connection to other people
that was somehow a standard that
was so deeply ingrained in the cells of
their body
that's the gold standard of what kind of
human being they were
and this is how they want to be
remembered a person of integrity
a person who was honest and loving and
caring
and humble and brought joy to other
people's lives
was an optimist or whatever it was but
it had
a very different flavor than what you
would typically think and then we
compared who you are at your best
and how you want to be remembered when
you're gone
and they were right there it was like
something important was being
represented
i really came to understand that there
is this hidden scorecard in
all of us even though we're chasing all
these extrinsic measures of success
we're going crazy and we think if i just
win one more
event if i win one more gold star if i
win one more
competitive victory i'll feel really
good about myself
but that is not the gold standard of how
you're going to evaluate
how your life was lived this hidden
score card i've found
so many people who've been number one in
the world i've been fortunate enough
to work with 17 number ones in the world
and get them there
and i can vividly remember the
conversations i've had
when they were number one they have this
sense of you know i
i still feel like i i don't feel
comfortable in my skin
i i need more i i don't know what it is
i'm not
this isn't what i thought it would be
i'm not that happy i don't feel that
fulfilled i don't know how i can be
number one maybe
two or three or four times again
and what i began to realize that they
were actually measuring themselves on a
scorecard
ultimately that was hidden a hidden
scorecard
and that was their treatment of others
and that they were not
scoring high on even though they climbed
to the top
they didn't have this connection to
family they weren't loving and kind to
maybe their siblings or even their
competitors and how they dealt with all
these other issues
every single day you're confronted by
some kind of stress
associated with a connection with other
persons
and they weren't scoring well on that
and so we began to realize that if we
want to grow
and have happiness high performance
fulfillment we've got to work both
scorecards
it's not one to the exclusion of others
and so that became
a big part of the journaling was
actually how do we build the muscles
of moral and ethical character and make
sure that i am living a life
that is aligned with that and my energy
reflects that more than winning
and that gives you a sense of peace and
actually that
enables you to go into competition and
feel
better about dan jansen realized and
this was a critical point
we had many conversations around this
that even if he didn't
win an olympic medal and when he said
i'm going to skate
out of this sense of joy and
gratefulness he was prepared
to leave the sport of speed skating
never to have won an olympic medal
because it was a gift
and and that could never be taken he was
revered by his competitors he's an
extraordinarily good person
and he had the sense that i'm to be okay
and this was a gift no matter what
happens if i get that that's icing on
the cake but i like who i
am and i like how i've dealt with these
things
so that for me was a critical lesson
that i've tried to
bring into this leading with character
book
that really helps to unearth
the scorecard that i think we all hold
you mentioned 17 number ones
you've worked with hundreds more i would
be really curious to know
what life patterns
you see between two groups if you had to
split
all of those people into two groups one
is
the groups or rather the group
that has this alignment and they're
scoring well on the hidden scorecard of
how they
treat others then the other group is
still at least for a period of time
represents
massively successful competitors just
kind of by definition if they're in that
group
17 or even in the broader group of 100
but who do not score well
on the hidden scorecard because i'm sure
there are people listening
who are thinking well wait a second but
i know about
this person in baseball this person in
cycling this person in fill in the blank
sport and those guys are
notorious [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and yet they still get these massive
endorsement contracts they
seem pretty happy they're making a ton
of money
they've got all the creature comforts in
the world
and i guess on some level there's a
waiting for the comeuppance right
there's a waiting for
the the fall yeah when is the shoe gonna
finally drop
right and so i'd love for you to speak
to
how you sort of incorporate
people witnessing that in the wider
world of sports or in business
also right what you say tim is 100 right
there is nothing to
say that a person who has very few in
fact
they don't you know let's say you're in
cycling and you
found that if you take
performance-enhancing drugs you can
dominate the field and you don't have
any
you know remorse or any hesitation doing
so and part of it is
you know we have this incredible moral
machinery which says hey everybody's
doing it
you have 101 reasons why it's okay and
we all are fighting this battle
we want to feel as good as we possibly
can we want to feel like a good person
but we also want to take as many
shortcuts as we can and win
and so we're always trying to get that
line how much can i do before i start so
we start invoking all these very
complex and very powerful mechanisms
motivated reasoning we we do uh
all kinds of things that actually you
know enable us
to get away with things that in our
sanest moments if i had an opportunity
to sit down with you
and actually think it through you would
if we bust through all these smoke and
mirrors
you realize this is not the person you
want to be even though
you know there's this group think
there's this what it called the
boomerang effect
and even though we have this thing
called motivated reasoning all your
reasoning now is
i want to win and these are things that
are helping me win and i can
you know i can make money i'm famous how
the hell is this not working as long as
i don't get caught
so we've learned in psychology we've
known it for a very long time
that drive was the single best predictor
of success
people who are driven angela duckworth
calls it grit
it takes a lot of different forms uh it
can be
persistence determination but
it means somehow this sport has captured
your
interest your passion and you come hell
or high water you're going to be good
and so what that drive does is that you
just
roll over setbacks roll over injuries
you are not to be denied and so we find
people who have even though they're they
don't have a lot of skill and talent
but they have this blue collar kind of
ethos and they're driven like maniacs
and they become
extraordinary performers just because
they're driven to then you have others
who are these we call the natural ones
who
don't have to work that hard but they're
willing to put up with it
and they just don't like failure you
know they just they don't like to fail
so they work hard enough so they don't
fail but
they don't have to put in nearly as much
work but drive
is the thing that separates them so i'm
lucky enough to have worked with you
know generation after generation of
great performers and i
i'm now working with the kids of people
who
i worked with when they were in the
prime of their career and i
i can see how their lives are playing
out and what happened and how what kind
of human beings they are
and i didn't have that perspective when
i was in the moment with them when they
were very young but when i see now
what's happened to their lives
what kind of mothers and fathers they've
become how are they treating their kids
when they're out in sports now i do they
understand what sport is all about and
the gift that it is to them or are they
these
enraged parents driving them and every
time their kids do badly
it's like a mark on their performance
and they literally take personally
everything that goes on with their kids
so i have this perspective and then we
have all this research to support
this understanding that there's a
difference between success
and how you define success if it's
strictly in terms
of titles money you know all these
extrinsic
markers if that's how we're going to
define success
you can have a great career
and have not that many moral and ethical
virtues that
define the journey you know what you do
is very different than how you do it
and so we have people who've climbed to
the top
and often they're really not that happy
and they've maybe created a lot of
dead bodies along the way and
maybe the fans don't even like them
because they can sense maybe their
arrogance their
the way in which they're treating others
and they the way they treat the press
the way they treat coaches they
hire and fire coaches and you know
whatever it is and they
they attack anyone who gets in the way
they've made a lot of money
and they have achieved a lot of success
they may even someday get into the hall
of fame but probably not
and then there's this thing we call
sustained success
and sustained success means that and
that again how do we define success
for me success is the ability to perform
at a very high level
and to do so in a way the how that
actually fulfills you
makes you feel like a complete human
being that you're proud of what you've
done and how you've done it
and it's enabled you to be a better
mother a better father better caring
person
a better member of your community i
think of someone like arnold palmer
i think of the legacy that federer and
nadal are leaving
this is not just a flash in the pan
there are a lot of people that get to a
certain level of competency
but they have gotten there strictly on
the basis of the skills they have
that i call performance skills they're
very skilled at focus
they have great drive motivation they
have discipline
they have great resiliency they've
learned to just fight like dogs they
have a lot of tough-mindedness
but when it comes to the how they've
done what they've done
there's something missing and they know
it and that's that hidden scorecard
and so i try to help anyone i'm working
with understand
how to build both of those up you know
my mother
was not a great performer she never
graduated from
college she was um
by any matter of me and she was not a
high performer
but she was an extraordinarily good
person she was kind
giving loving trusting i mean she was a
model of goodness
and she never achieved that much but she
was a extraordinarily happy woman
and then i have people who i know who
are extraordinarily
high achievers in a family and
they have virtually no connection to
family members the only thing they do is
maybe
provide financial support when people
get in trouble but there's no connection
and uh so for me i'm looking
my mother and my father my father was a
person of unbelievable integrity
he came from a town of 400
very poor family and he worked a trap
line
to actually get food for his family
and it was a small little town called
defiance
iowa 400 i think there are about 287
people there now
but somehow his parents gave him
integrity and he carried that forward
when ana became an extraordinary
baseball player
and he got hurt and then he worked his
way
he had no money whatsoever very poor he
worked his way through
school and went through engineering
school and uh
when i think about someone the two
greatest gifts i've had in my life
were not because my parents were high
achievers but
my mom was no achiever except an
extraordinary mother my father became a
very high achiever
but he did it in the right way and he
taught all of us
now that i am truly reflecting on those
things
the value of integrity honesty and
gratefulness
and balance in one's life between
striving
and actually just giving back to others
and striving for your own identity and
giving back to others
so i feel very grateful about that and
it has coincided with my research
and with all the work that i've been
able to do over so many years
thank you so much for that background i
didn't actually know the family
background
which which adds a lot of texture to the
cloth
if that makes any sense in terms of
understanding
the upbringing and the lens with which
you look at
a lot of these things also very very
helpful
i was thinking as you were talking also
that how we
judge high performers or evaluate them
is a bit of a rorschach test for
ourselves
also and the reason this came to mind i
was simultaneously thinking of two
things
one was the last dance
with michael jordan and how some of my
friends
have said in effect this
shows you exactly what i always
suspected which is you cannot be the
best
in any sport without being a driven
[ __ ] on some level now in fairness to
michael jordan i did not come out of
that thinking that that he was an
[ __ ] but
it was interesting to me to see some of
my friend driven friends
who in some areas are definitely take no
prisoners when it all costs
who view life through a somewhat
mercenary lens and i'm not saying
they're right or wrong i'm just saying
that's the lens
looked at the last dance as evidence
that that was the truth that you you had
to be an [ __ ] and yet
you mentioned a name roger federer so i
do not know
federer well by any stretch of the
imagination got to shake his hand once
at a
fundraiser that andy roddick put on and
in austin and a number of people got up
to speak
about federer and it seems like and
again
who knows but the coverage
and discussion and maybe even legend of
federer
is entirely the opposite it seems
it's exactly the opposite so we have
this counterpoint
and i guess it just goes to show
that you know there are multiple paths
and that there's so much unseen right we
don't know what the long-term
taxes are that you pay necessarily in
either of those individual lives
for michael jordan or roger federer
and i think some maybe those who are
watching the last dance and saying see i
told you so
is that they perceive that as being
easier more efficient
a better use of energy because you're
not handling the world with kid gloves
and having to take into account everyone
else's emotions
what do you think of that i know i'm
monologuing a little bit i'm thinking
out loud but
is it easier to go one way or the other
or is it just a better investment up
front to think about
practicing kindness along the way
because ultimately
you will reap what you sow and have to
live with yourself 20 years later i mean
this is all kind of speculation on my
part but i
just i'd love to hear if any of that
brain vomit i just imposed on you
triggers any thoughts in your mind well
you raise a
a really great issue and you know you
you see
contrasting styles there are as you said
there are many paths to winning
and michael jordan as tiger woods
they were driven from the earliest days
i
often think about the kind of resilience
that michael jordan had
when he got cut from his high school
basketball team because he didn't have
the right stuff i'd
love to know how the coach felt who cut
him from the basketball team
because he didn't have it and he became
one of the maybe the greatest of all
time
michael was driven if you had one thing
he didn't show the talent early in his
career but
he devoted every single cell in his body
he was mr intensity
he didn't care what barrier was in front
of him
and once team members were solidified he
was going to make everyone better
because he wanted to win
he didn't care about anything unless it
helped the team win
and for him to be perhaps the greatest
ever
he was an extraordinarily powerful
influence on everyone around him in
terms of
stepping up giving more energy giving
everything you had
he gave everything he had in practice
far more than
anyone had ever seen his teammates are
going what the heck
who does this in practice and michael
would respond
you win games in practice if you do it
right in practice
the intensity of a game is easy and then
when he gets sick
and he's in the playoffs and he has the
flu
and he's not even sure he'd get up off
the bench he mobilizes himself
and so the question i have is what in
the heck is driving you
and i think i mean i've never had an
opportunity to sit down with michael i
think i've read
everything about him but never had the
opportunity to
have a conversation with him i think he
would say that he was driven
from the earliest years to be a winner
and he would accept nothing short of
that and he knew that eventually he
began to realize that it was his energy
and his intensity and his dedication
to that mission that actually broke him
free and enabled him to do things that
no one else could do
and he ignited his talent energy ignites
talent
we never know how much we have until we
actually put ourselves on the line
so what would have happened if during
that same period
he had uh spent some of his energy
working on his hidden scorecard and the
way he went to the top would it have
taken away some of the intensity that he
would have
that he would accept nothing but total
success
would it have deflated some of that and
not
enabled him to achieve the heights that
he would have achieved you know that's a
question i
i can't answer i can only tell you that
fulfillment and satisfaction in one's
life
comes i've seen it over and over and
over again so i
and i didn't have this understanding and
this is something i wish i had known
these things
when i was much younger in my career
even as a father
of three sons i wish i knew it earlier
but
i just know that someone like roger is
another example
i mean as a junior no one knew that he
was going to
grow up to be the most dominant and most
extraordinary one of the most
extraordinary players in the history of
tennis
and he also was driven you know he was
he had a temporary he had to control
himself he had to
but there is a balance and you see it
he's a family man he brings his
kids on the road he has twins and you
can see the
devotion he has to his wife and he is
changing diapers out on the tour
and he's excited by it he's figured out
there is a way to help him and i believe
it's helped him to become a better
player even than the
later stages of his career is he a
perfect human being i'm sure
he is not and neither is michael jordan
but what i'm looking for is a that sense
of
balance in a person's life that they
haven't given it all up
and then at some point in their life
realize what the hell is that all about
so i'm the greatest
basketball player in the history of the
game so far
but i'm i'm empty i don't feel like i
really
i don't feel like that was what i was
put on planet earth to do
what the hell did i do here and so i
think there is
an establishment of what your noble
purpose is for being here
mark twain once said the two most
important days
in your life are the day you were born
and the day you find out why we found
that purpose is the single
most important element
that releases energy once you understand
that purpose and you
develop a sense of what that is you
could say you know i'm going to become
the most extraordinary basketball player
in the history of the game
in the hope that i can inspire others to
the beauty of this game
and to how one can do this and give back
extraordinarily to great causes
when you look at the impact that roger
and his wife
have had on africa on educating young
boys and girls in africa
and all the effort he's done the schools
and i mean it's
absolutely almost unimaginable and he
has committed that even when he didn't
have these
amazing financial resources that he has
now and he will do it until his
last breath and he has friends that have
been with him forever
and he has perspective i remember
a coach that was working with him told
me this story he said you know he lost
in a five setter in a grand slam and
everyone expected him to win
and he was down to the wire and i won't
say he was playing against but
obviously it was a great he had this
huge party planned afterwards
to celebrate this grand slam victory
and everyone you know was just thinking
well
how how was roger going to take this
and uh he gave this amazing speech after
the loss so gracious great perspective
and then his coach came up and said i
suppose we'll be canceling the party
after this because of what happened and
roger goes what
he says absolutely not i want to
celebrate i want to be with my friends i
want to you know this was
i got to the finals i didn't win but
what an extraordinary opportunity i had
here to really
push me to my limits i know things i
need to learn
i'll reflect on it but this is no way i
want to go out and have a great time
tonight
blew everyone away and that was why
the losses didn't eat him alive because
that was the only thing he was on planet
earth for
and that was to win another grand slam
title and be the greatest ever
what a great story and i just want to
say something that
people who are tennis wonks and really
know all the specs
and feeds of the various players will
not
find this surprising but certainly as
someone who
only recognized a handful of names
in tennis and really didn't know much
about tennis but had
heard stories of these seven foot giants
who just served down
upon their opponents like you know
goliath
shooting a missile launcher at a
downward angle and i expected in my mind
i suppose federer to be like some of the
descriptions of william wallace from
braveheart right he's eight and a half
feet tall and he's got blah blah blah i
just thought he was gonna be this
larger-than-life kind of freak of nature
as a human specimen and he looks like a
normal dude
like you would not pick him out of the
crowd no at all
and he's a normal person when you're
with him i mean he's the most normal
he's you know he doesn't have this big
you know if you're the great one of the
greatest if not the greatest ever
you would think he'd be a little
arrogant there's not an arrogant bone in
his body he's just a normal guy that
says yeah i've been pretty fortunate i
really like what i've done i love tens i
have this love affair with tennis and i
will play it till the end of my life
as long as i can and but i love my
family i love my life i love being able
to help people and
i'm really fortunate that's how he talks
that's how he thinks
question for you and this may seem like
a silly or mundane question but we were
just talking about
the last dance which i just thought was
a spectacularly well done
it was extraordinarily serious so well
done
i mean the amount of work that you get
you get goosebumps
multiple times over and over even though
you know the story
oh it's so good it's so so good and i
came away
all the more fascinated by multiple
characters including
michael jordan uh dennis rodman who i
knew next to nothing about aside from
the the crazy haircuts and everything
what other films
mini series books anything about
sports or specific figures or teams in
sports
have you found to leave a lasting
impression on you besides
the last dance i'll offer one which is
senna
about erica which is a phenomenal
phenomenal documentary that had a really
big impact on me
actually recommended to me by joe gebbia
who is
co-founder of airbnb who's been on the
podcast are there any other
docs movies anything at all that come to
mind you know i love
espn's 30 for 30. i adored the one
on andre agassi i love the story the
documentary on ray
mancini's life this is you know food for
my soul
i just love these inside i love the
inside story
because that's kind of the world i live
in and a lot of the stories i can't tell
but i've
i have such deep appreciation when the
honesty and authenticity of an athlete
is out there i love to be moved you know
i just love to be moved
so i i don't have one that you know
really is
i mean there's been so many stories on
the dan jansen so many documentaries and
there's one that it shows him at the end
in the final
and i used to play it a lot when i was
hanging around just because it got me up
and i literally cry
every single time i watch it i can't
watch it without going into tears
because i was so happy for dan
and so joyous with him in what he had
achieved and how he did it
and sometimes i'm a sucker for movies
because
i get moved you know if you were to ask
me what is my
my favorite doc i mean my favorite
movies
in some genre i would say and probably
your audience has no idea what i'm even
talking about
but i i love the western genre
and i love lonesome dove and the return
to lonesome dove
i literally can watch that 10 times
and it moves me every single time i
don't know what it is
about those two uh shows that move me so
powerfully but
i guess i'm kind of uh i love great
acting
and i love robert duvall i think he's
one of the most brilliant actors that
brings out such nuances in how people
feel and he became gus mccray
and tommy lee jones i mean i remember
robert duvall
saying of all the things that he did in
his lifetime
what was the one that he actually was
most memorable to him and he said i
became gus mcrae and lonesome dove
i became that character and it's exactly
what happened
it was unbelievable how he immersed
himself in that person
and he was indistinguishable from that
person when i see a
a documentary on an athlete and i i see
them
really revealing kind of their inner
soul and what the demons they had to
face
like andre how he had to face so many
issues
and he was able to transcend them and
become
absolutely an entirely different person
someone that we all so admire and
and then he you know ascended to a
height that was much greater he'd become
number one
and he had all these demons driving him
and no fulfillment and then suddenly
he reaches this epiphany
about what the purpose of his life was
as mark twain said
and he devoted his life to something
that was really meaningful and that was
to help kids have
something that he always wanted to have
himself security in his
education and so he developed a charter
school in all of his fame and all of his
tennis legend
was devoted to raising money and to
making that happen
and in his hall of fame induction he had
a couple of the kids who were there and
they described what had happened to them
because of this school that andre had
funded
andre became a different person he
became an extraordinary human being in
my judgment
and steffy graf played a big role in
that
but he got his purpose right and he
aligned his life with his purpose
and he helped so many people in the
process and he became a much better
competitor he
he went to number one in the world again
and dominated like he had never
dominated before and it wasn't just
a flash in the pan now
it was something he could sustain
because he was there for the right
reason
well i think that is a great place to
start to wrap
up and man agassi's story
what a story just a second that holy cow
yeah i i don't i don't cry much
but when i do not sound like the
beer commercial but it is it was
frequently when reading open
the autobiography yeah what a wonderful
book huh
absolutely fantastic smokes one of the
great reads
i would recommend everyone pick up
because it it's there's the authenticity
in that book
and i knew andre at the academy i've
known him all the years
and what a transformation occurred in
him and
it was a transformation that
should inspire all of us and it is
around the notion of purpose
it really is that that's a such a
fantastic
example i'm really happy you brought
that up and jim
this has been so much fun i'm glad we
were finally able
to hop on the podcast to have a
conversation like this
for more people to listen to than just
the two of us
the new book is leading with character
you've written many many books you've
spent decades
doing experiments looking at the applied
research
working with top performers i've spent
time
with you you walk the talk i really
appreciate who you are and what you do
in the world
people can find you on the website jim
hyphen lair
loehr.com we'll link to the book we'll
link to everything
in the show notes for people tim dot
blog forward slash podcast
is there anything else that you would
like to say any request of the audience
suggestion to the audience anything at
all that you would like to
share and some closing comments or
questions before
we wrap up you know well first of all
i'd just like to thank you for the
opportunity
uh to interact with you again i have
great respect for you and what you've
done and the impact that you've had it's
stunning i mean it's actually
you are a top performer and you're
really interested in getting to the
nitty-gritty of issues it's not just a
normal
conversation there's an authenticity
there that i think that's what draws
people to which i think is really a
terrific thing
and i feel privileged to be involved in
that effort that you're putting forth
the other thing i would say to our
listeners i would really appreciate
as you go through the material and if
you can stay with the journaling
i'd love to have feedback i'd love to i
love data i'd love for you to tell me
the impact that this has had
how reading the book what kind of impact
but more importantly
what was the impact of the journaling
and did you get the
the notion that now you have it doesn't
make moral and ethical life any simpler
but you have much more confidence that
the decision that you've made
is going to be more aligned with who you
really want to be through thick and thin
and i would just love to have that
request that
i'd love to have any feedback that you
have
around this because i spent the last
decade of my life putting that together
researching it and i just
i'd love to have feedback so if that's
something they can do i'd love it
what is the best way for them to provide
feedback without
blowing your privacy on this rather
public forum
is it is it leaving blog comments on
the blog post that'll be associated with
this podcast episode is it leaving
comments for you on linkedin is there a
particular channel that you would
suggest
yeah they can do it on linkedin they can
go ahead on my website
and you know indicate that they have an
interest in
or just do that but they can actually
put comments in
on the linkedin and if they have an
interest we'll will definitely get
connected
so there are a variety of ways to do it
and i want to make it as easy as
possible
well i will not uh will not be giving
any google maps
satellite views of your house to this
audience
but those who are motivated those who
are
impacted and i'm sure there will be more
than a few can find you
at jim heifenler.com and also on
linkedin very easily and i'll include
all of those in the show notes
also thank you jim for the very kind
words i really appreciate
you saying what you did and i hope we
get to
spend some time in person again and i'd
love to
yeah and i wish you continued success
and just keep
far north or south of that coven
let's try to try to keep ahead of it
it's these short legs i gotta really
maintain a high rpm uh so i'm jealous of
your size 15s even though you're not
seven feet tall you are taller than i am
and big feet are not exactly
uh a gift they're kind of a kind of a
curse
so we'll we'll cover that in round two
so to be continued uh jim thank you
again for the time
and thank you for everybody else it's
been a real pleasure real pleasure
absolutely
on this side as well and to everybody
listening
until next time do exactly what jim
gave as the answer for what he would put
on a billboard that billions might see
metaphorically speaking that is practice
kindness that is one of the messages i
think
of absolutely what we've been talking
about that is a through line
and until next time thank you for
listening
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short it's just a little tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by 99 designs
the global creative platform that makes
it easy for you to find and work with
amazing graphic designers online
long time listeners of this podcast know
how much attention i paid to detail
how obsessively i approach nearly all
elements of my work
because the small things often end up
being the big thing so whether it's your
logo
your business cards website design even
your email templates all of these visual
elements
tell your customers tell your users who
you are and what you're about
so i think it's worth sweating the
details i've been using 99designs for
years now
to ensure that many of my creative
projects whether big or small
are as cohesive professional and
beautiful as possible
i've worked on draft mockups and book
covers
i've worked on all sorts of things most
recently i've been working with a
designer at 99designs to update the
illustrations and layouts
for all of my downloadable ebooks i've
developed a really great working
relationship
with designer who goes by the username
spoon lancer and
i intend to continue working with him to
bring ideas to life one project
at a time i've also used 99 designs for
all sorts
of high-end illustration for different
books like the tao of seneca you can see
a bunch of examples on my instagram that
i've put up
and they've turned out better than i
possibly could have hoped
so from logos to websites to packaging
to books
99designs is the go-to creative resource
to build your brand on any budget
so check them out right now my listeners
that's you guys can get 20
off plus a free 99 upgrade on
their first design contest contest is a
great way to get started and find the
right designer
for long-term work you can also book a
free design
consultation with a brand expert at
99designs to receive personalized
branding advice over the phone
their hands-on team has helped thousands
of business owners at this point it's a
great way to get the most out of your
experience with 99 designs
so take a look head to 99designs.com
tim for your discount and to sign up for
design consultation
today that's 99designs.com
tim this podcast episode is brought to
you by helix
sleep sleep is super important to me in
the last few years
i've come to conclude it is the end-all
be-all that all good things
good mood good performance good
everything seem to stem
from good sleep so i've tried a lot to
optimize it i've tried pills and potions
all sorts of different mattresses you
name it and the last few years i've been
sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
and like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helix
sleep.com tim take their two-minute
sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up from
you if you don't love it
and now my dear listeners helix is
offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim these are not
cheap pillows either so getting two for
free is an
upgraded deal so that's up to 200 off
and two free pillows at helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim for up to 200
off so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
tim